That's the thing that gets me
with this Flint crisis,
is why does it take so long
for people to act on this?
I just don't get it, you guys.
Story's not sexy enough, Larry!
Oh, w... Hey!
Grace Parra, everyone!
-(cheering and applause)
-Hello, hello. Hi. -All right.
Okay, what do you mean the story
is not sexy enough, Grace?
Well, you're talking
about lead pipes,
infrastructure funding,
civil engineering.
If you want people
to take action
in these United States
of America,
you got to sex your story up.
Okay, but...
I mean, Grace,
how-how do you sex up
something like
the Flint water crisis?
-Oh, I don't know.
Well, actually, I do know. -Oh.
Here's a little public service
announcement I put together
with my friends.
(sultrily): What's happening
in Flint is just foreplay.
If we're not careful,
it's gonna get real, real bad.
(echoing):
Real bad.
Across the country,
from Washington D.C.
to Sebring, Ohio, up to
10 million homes and businesses
are taking it from lead pipe.
So if there's one thing
we've learned from Flint,
-it's that...
-We've got to take
Michigan Governor Rick Snyder
down!
-Take him down!
-Whoa, whoa, Holly.
I mean... it's that someone's
got to lay a ton of new pipe.
But we need somebody man enough
to do it.
We need someone to unscrew
the old and screw in the new.
(echoing):
Screw.
All night long.
'Cause right now,
that Flint water is oh so dirty.
-Too dirty.
-(echoing): Too dirty.
Don't you want
to help us get wet?
Don't you? Don't you,
you cost-cutting,
poor-hating bastards?!
-Grace!
-I'm sorry.
(echoing):
Get wet.
THEDE: But water utility budgets
across the country
have been tied up or cut down,
leaving us helpless.
And, fellas,
I'm just not into that.
(chuckles)
Listen, this needs to be
a national conversation.
We all need to come together
at the exact same time.
(echoing):
City water.
Please don't make us wait.
Because people
could (bleep) die!
-(indistinct arguing) -No, no!
They won't listen to anger!
-(sighing)
-Okay.
Please, gentlemen, legislate,
regulate,
and fund water infrastructure.
Trust us.
ALL:
You won't regret it.
The women of The Nightly Show,
everyone!
We haven't forgotten you, Flint!
We have not forgotten!
We'll be right back!